und julian haben sich getrennt
das können mir eigentlich egal nicht
sein allerdings sind wir glaube ich alle
so ein bisschen mit den zweien und deren
super kraska exklusive rufe diebe
konnten aufgewachsen und her kamen diese
meldung schon sehr überraschend vor
allem auf die art und weise wie sie
rüber gebracht wurde so leute
den spekulationen ein ende setzen ich
mache es kurz und schmerzlos ja es
stimmt wir uns getrennt wie hat sich
getrennt julian co hat wirklich einfach
eine story hochgeladen auf instagram und
hat gesagt dass die gerüchte stimmen die
beiden sich getrennt haben
falls sie von dem gerücht nichts
mitbekommen habt gebt ihr glaube ich
hinterm mond beim eine komplette for you
page ist seit tagen voll damit dass
gegen beide nichts posten keine ahnung
was da steht überall auch darin dass bei
julian feldmann aus der familie
gestorben sein könnte weil wir der
schwester von juli an eine schwarze rose
in der bio war also ich wollte mich da
nicht einmischen ich will mich auch
jetzt sich einmischen aber es sinn macht
gerade wenn du dich mal dieser sturm
hier im hamburger hafen julian hat
übrigens auch noch immer in seiner
instagram bio stehen herz- babys beauty
palace und auch bibi hat das doch da
drinstehen die haben halt auch noch alle
gemeinsamen bilder und so drin wie
beispielsweise das hier voll süß so in
dubai und auch mit dem text alles gute
zum 155 monats sagt ja die waren länger
zusammenhalt sandra nachhilfestunden für
sie genommen hat und das waren einige
jahre mir ist gerade mal aufgefallen
hätten wir jede stunde unserer beziehung
einen handelsüblichen schokoriegel
verdrückt hätten wir mittlerweile 16,3
millionen kilokalorien zu uns genommen
unsere beziehung ist etwas besonderes so
sondern stand es dann glaube ich leider
doch nicht gewesen zu sein und versteht
mich nicht falsch ich will mich
überhaupt nicht irgendwie darüber lustig
machen oder die beiden jetzt wissen oder
fertig machen das ja immer schon gesagt
ich kenne die beiden kaum
persönlich habe die nur einmal besoffen
gesehen bei irgendeiner university vor
sieben jahren oder so und ich will mich
auch wirklich kein urteil erlauben
allerdings gibt es hätte gerüchte
darüber dass bibi fremdgegangen sein
könnte
und ich habe ja auch schon mal auf babys
erstes youtube-video in ihren jeweiligen
kanal beauty lounge die wie reagiert das
hier war nämlich babys aller allererster
youtube-kanal beauty lounge die ideen
hat sie noch vor babys beauty palace
gehabt und als diese sachen hochgeladen
wie beispielsweise anleitung mittel
gegen tränensäcke widerlich rundes
gesicht schmaler mund voluminös
schminken augenbrauen trimmen handtuch
in den kopf wickeln seitens oft
schlechten herbst make up keine ahnung
sieht man's gesagt alles mögliche hat
sich hochgeladen
und im zuge dessen hat sie auf ihrem
zwei kanal dieses video hier
und das video
schauen wir uns im rahmen der kompletten
trennungs und fremdgeh gerüchte
geschichte jetzt auch mal ganz kurz an
es ist überhaupt nicht wie man sollte
nicht fremdgehen das ist das schlimmste
was man eine beziehung antun kann
allerdings sollte man jetzt recht keine
tipps geben öffentlich im internet an
300.000 leute wie man so etwas gut
machen und verheimlichen kann also ja ok
bibi hat dieses video vor zehn jahren
hochgeladen und mittlerweile selber
darauf auch wiederum reagiert und
stellung dazu bezogen zusammen mit
julian zusammenarbeit jetzt irgendwie
anscheinend selber gemerkt ich will die
gerüchteküche nicht anreisen sondern was
es gibt bilder und videos von baby wie
sie mit einem anderen typen gesehen
wurde an einem eis laden restaurant in
london keine ahnung was und dann auch
noch ein typ der anscheinend auch schon
kontakt mit julia hat die julia hat den
auch mal irgendwann erwähnt und
traurigen screenshot und dann
jemand erzählt der tennessee dass er hat
erzählt dass man
aber wir schauen uns jetzt mal an was
bibel überhaupt so für tipps in der
richtung fremdgehen für uns hart
mit diesen kommunizieren müssen kontakt
halten muss allerdings sollte das nicht
über eure normale e mail adresse machen
legt euch hier für eine ersatz e mail
adresse an die ihr halt eigentlich nur
kennt e mail adresse
vor zehn jahren war lassen sich über
email-adressen irgendwie verabredet
also extra zum fremdgehen am besten ganz
neue ihr handy kaufen neue identität
schaffen
richtigen terminkalender abstimmen mit
der person mit der man fremd geht und
dass
beispielsweise restaurant mitten in
london danach trage aus dem schnitt eben
ich habe das waren stuttgart
[Musik]
es wäre skandalös wenn julia davon
mitbekommen hätte mensch gab es da nicht
auch tech talks wo gesehen wurde dass
julian da vielleicht schon eine ansicht
hatte
dann werden wir uns trennen und du wirst
du 1
außerdem
solltet ihr euch nach einem treffen am
besten
es ist halt krass das baby das einfach
sofort hochgeladen hat und anscheinend
jetzt perfektioniert hat aber gut okay
ich will mich da auch gar nicht so weit
ein bisschen ich meine ist kommt
irgendwie alles hin julian wirkt sehr
sehr fertig in dieser story die
hochgeladen hat übrigens hat bibi
währenddessen die story vom friseur
gepostet
aber wie bereits gesagt wir wissen nicht
was davon wirklich stimmt was der
wahrheit entspricht ich meine gerade es
macht sehr viel sinn und das was man
halt durch diese ganze tik tok polizei
und die ganzen detektive auf dieser
plattform so mitkriegt was du in videos
für andeutungen waren wenn man all das
zusammen nimmt und ein großes puzzle aus
diesen ganzen teilen form dann ergibt
das sinn leider ich bin gespannt ob die
sich dazu noch äußern wird
wahrscheinlich noch beim friseur ich
weiß auch nicht ob die beiden das
geplant haben dass sie es jetzt
öffentlich machen oder das julian
darunter sehr gelitten hat und irgendwie
einfach mit der weiter rausrücken wollte
aber ich würde denken wenn man zwei
kinder hat oder drei mittlerweile keine
ahnung die auch irgendwann demnächst mal
vernünftig richtig nachdenken können uns
auch hinterfragen können und die dann
mit dieser sache so umzugehen haben dass
sich die eltern getrennt haben weil
vielleicht nie fremdgegangen ist und
dann wurde julian unser vaterland zu
tage stellte mit der nada es ist blöd
und ich bin doch ganz ehrlich mich lässt
das an der wahren liebe zweifeln weil
für mich war es immer so jahr menschen
kommen menschen gehen justin und selena
gomez opfer bei kommunale sehr lieb
gehabt sie mehr brad pitt angelina jolie
okay mein gott nada und luisa haben wir
noch aber bibi und julian also das ding
war schon zusammen ich bin ich auch
gespannt wie sich das jetzt machen mit
diesen ganzen häusern immobilien ist hat
überlegen haben sich als schüler gedatet
kennengelernt und
millionäre ich hab auch die hat ja
vertraglich an dass das also jetzt ein
ganz wilder gedanken wenn ich mich jetzt
von ihr trennen würde dass ich mich dann
scheiden lassen musste das hast du schon
mal darüber nachgedacht
ja
das haben wir auch im podcast gesagt
vor ein paar wochen
es ist
es ist irgendwie krass wenn man alles so
zusammen nimmt aber noch krasser ist es
meiner ansicht nach wenn man sich
wirklich die instagram accounts von
einerseits julian co anguckt wie jedes
foto nahezu mit bibi gegen mir
entstanden ist und dann halt auch auf
babys account sieht dass sie noch
verlinkt hat und auch extrem viele
bilder einfach mit julian zusammen sind
mit der kompletten familie und das alles
mit sehr oft gerade
es ist schon
krass außenstehende personen
mitzubekommen wenn ich bin ganz ehrlich
bei uns wird es eine gruppe geschickt
und alle meinten hosenträger
mich würd's mehr jucken wenn sack reis
umfallen würde als was die beiden und
ihrer beziehungen und so soll es ja auch
sein das ist deren beziehung allerdings
stand ist halt so krass in der
öffentlichkeit und da sind sie selbst
dran schuld sie haben das halt damit
auch gelebt sie haben viele spicy fragen
beantwortet haben kinder die auch auf
die öffentlich keit gezerrt wurden es
ist dann natürlich auch logisch dass da
leute drüber reden besonders natürlich
auch ich der die beiden jetzt natürlich
nicht richtig kennt aber ich hab schon
dass die sachen können reagiert ich habe
sie auch in letzter zeit ein bisschen in
mein herz geschlossen wenn julian hat
sich so eine video serie von mir
abgeguckt und
das fand ja auch ganz cool habe ich auch
kommentiert und ich bin der content von
den hatte auch eine gute richtung
entwickelt klar solche gewinnspiele
brauchen jetzt nicht unbedingt im
internet aber gut männer lieben freund
ich will gar nicht mehr lange über den
ganzen kram zu quatschen schreibt euch
an eure meinung zu der ganzen geschichte
wird ihn also an sicht auf die dinge und
in die kommentare sandra hatte podcast
gesagt die meinte seien krank ich habe
gesagt wenn das ein projekt ist auch mal
einen fallschirmsprung ihr wisst dass
ich mein leben nicht an zwei seile an
einen regenschirm packen will aber das
kann kein krank sein und wenn es einen
krank ist schande über euch spielt ob
das macht man nicht ich glaube die haben
sich wirklich getrennt man hätte es ganz
bisschen cooler machen können ich glaube
dass das auch nicht ganz freiwillig war
von bibi dass sie das wollte dass julian
das jetzt direkt zu öffentlich mache das
ist meiner ansicht ich wünsche den
beiden alles gute einzeln getrennt
voneinander
weltfrieden